mj's with us in phoenix good afternoon
mj how can i help
hey this was a pleasure thank you
awesome this is my call
ah thank you for calling i i yeah i
have a really stupid question this is
the mom question um
i have a son that is 36 years old and we
have two boys and they both have worked
two jobs all their life
a full-time and a part-time job but
anyhow our son
april or 20 20 to 36 year old sold his
place
and you know what happened afterwards um
and so and he sold his place paid all
his debt off which is awesome he said
that's great
and and my dog in houston when rarely
home so he said just can't vote at our
place because
you know it's not like anybody's very
very often there
but anyhow now a year plus later poor
guy the housing market here instead of
taking a dump after the election
has his might he's not making enough
money for as far as
the houses are going up and the poor guy
i just
if you have any advice for a kid working
really hard
well young man sorry 36 working really
hard
um two things um how do you keep going
when you have to choose between church
and sleep
you know it's one of those things to
full-time jobs and then
also you know for more than a year or
two
but um he's already done over a year but
also where do you put your money so that
it'll
grow fast um at this point everybody's
putting 40 to 50 000 at least
over asking price if you can find a
house out here
so any advice yeah so let's let's
let's let's backtrack so i can make sure
you have all the right information you
have a 36 year old son
sounds like he's he he was making some
good decisions
sold the house paid off all of his debt
you allowed him to come back home for a
season so he can do these kind of things
but unfortunately due to the housing
market right now
it's been a little difficult for him to
get back out and to purchase another
home correct
okay exactly yeah and and basically the
the home prices are outpacing the money
he's making and has
and so at this point the poor guy i mean
about once a month i end up at home
and and he's ready to throw the troll
one but not really
don't explain the next day after you've
got some sleep yeah yeah you know but
you can you can do anything for a season
my husband and i both work two jobs
yeah so you can do anything for a season
and um our dad is almost paid off so he
knows and we all know
that it's possible but any advice
for hanging in there during this time
and
here's here's my question now mj huh you
know i
yeah you got a good son okay uh
but yeah but here's yeah here's my
question
why does he how come he still can't move
out and get an apartment
why why do we have to wait to go
purchase a home because
at 36 years old working two jobs
no debt mj there's no reason he should
be home
he can go rent an apartment he can go
rent a house
and he can be saving until he is in a
position to purchase a home
exactly exactly yes and depending
unfortunately for him when he told his
house of pandemic was just starting
and so anyhow we told him yeah six
months a year that's fine
and we honestly because we don't use our
house very much you know
is is totally fine that he's there
that's not a problem no no no no no
it totally can be on his own yeah yeah
there's this is not about it puts you
and your husband
um in a bind this is about your son is
my
age okay with
no financial responsibilities that's
scary
okay now i can see if he was home trying
to pay off
i still couldn't see that at 36 shoulder
i'm gonna be honest with you i think
anybody in their 30s
unless it's a medical issue um or a
major life issue
no one in their 30s especially a man
should be at home
okay so i'm i'm going to respectfully
push back on you and say mother
you need to go ahead and just let your
son know hey son go get an apartment
because what we want to do is some we
want to help you get ready for your wife
your wife doesn't want to meet you when
you at home living off of us and you
working two jobs like there's no reason
here so let let's get back out there um
you've paid off all your debt
now go live your life become the best
man that you possibly can be
um and and take on some ownership for
your life and i get it mj it doesn't put
you and your husband in a bad place i
totally get it you are
great mama you remind me of my mama my
mama would let me come back home today
and my mama will let me live there until
i'm 50. now my daddy
he ain't allowing it he my pops ain't
going out okay
uh but encouragement for your son is
just to get back out there going ahead
and work
those two jobs keep that momentum going
um
going ahead and um save
save save as much as he can until
he is in a position to purchase a home i
get it the market right now is crazy
it's not just in your area in arizona
that's here in asheville
i can live i just moved into my house
and i can sell my house for fifty
thousand dollars more than what i bought
it for
already and i just moved into it a few
months ago
so the housing market is for the seller
it's not for the buyer
and so i if i'm him at his age right now
um i'm renting um and and i may i may
stop working two or three jobs you know
i may just work one so i can get back
into my local church so i can
have a little bit more of my freedom i
don't have any responsibilities
at this present time i don't have a
family i don't have any kids i don't
have any debt
i just i just need to live and and if he
lives below his means
he'll be all right uh but when it comes
to parking the money
um especially when it comes to
purchasing a home don't worry about
putting your money somewhere to where it
can grow fast
just go ahead and put it into a money
market account or you can park it online
on a
online savings account maybe like a
percent uh because pre-covet
online savings account was right around
two three percent money market accounts
right around uh 1.5 uh but now
anything is is a good return on the
savings it's like 0.5 to
maybe like 0.9 percent maybe 1 so i'll
just put it into a money market account
a savings account
keep stacking in there as much as i
possibly can and then once he is in a
position to where he can go out there
and purchase something
because i think we're going to be seeing
this for about at least another 12 to 18
months
and so if he wants to wait 12 to 18
months to stack up some more money and
then when the housing prices
maybe uh even out and they're not going
way above
the value of the home then he can get
back into it
but mj you have a great heart and listen
to me america i believe a lot of you
mothers out there have a great heart
like my mama
but i do believe men at 36 years old
need to be out on their own and taking
responsibility for their own life
and we can't do that if we're at home
and mom and dad is paying all of our
bills
so that's just my two cents
you know if dave was here
he would agree